la dernière fois on a parlé de
l'émergence d'une intelligence
artificielle de niveau humain pour fixer
les idées on va être un peu plus précis
et considérer le cas d'une ya capable de
passer une version forte du test de
turing le test de turing
rappelez vous on en a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 3 on l'appelle aussi le jeu de
limitation il s'agit d'un test
d'intelligence proposé par turing en
1950 où une intelligence artificielle
doit parvenir à se faire passer pour un
humain lorsque l'on 4 avec lui disons
sur twitter si on parle longuement un
compte twitter y compris en cherchant le
piéger pour tester si s'agit d'un humain
et cie ont conclu que notre
interlocuteur est un humain alors qu'il
s'agissait d'une machine alors la
machine aux commandes du compte twitter
aura passé le test de turing comme on en
a déjà parlé
le test de turing est vraiment un
problème très difficile pour les ir
puisqu'elles doivent être capables de
comprendre toutes les subtilités de la
langue et réagir un nombre exponentiel
de contexte imaginables pour ce faire
elles devront absolument extraire une
sémantique de nos discussions c'est à
dire disposer d'une façon de compresser
l'information à ce qu'elle a de plus
essentiel et elle devrait être capable
de manipuler la sémantique pour ensuite
répondre de manière intelligente
bref tout ça pour dire qu'une ya qui
saura vraiment passé le test de turing
le paiement se faisant passer pour un
humain brillant plutôt que prend en
ukrainien de 13 ans qui parle mal
l'anglais
une telle loi pourrait bien n'être en
tout point au moins aussi intelligente
que l'homme et on a vu dans l'épisode
précédent que selon les chercheurs on y
a une telle vie à deux niveaux humain
pourrait voir le jour dans un avenir pas
si lointain en particulier une bonne
proportion des chercheurs en ya en ce
que cette ia existera avant 2050 selon
ces chercheurs ou non en fait des
chances d'êtres vivants quand saisir
perd 11 jours et ce n'est pas de ça dont
je veux parler aujourd'hui ce dont
j'aimerais vous parler n'est pas d'une
intelligence artificielle de niveau
humain ce dont j'aimerais vous parler
ces deux super intelligence et par son
intense à penser que l'ia restera deux
niveaux demain sauf que l'intelligence
humaine n'a aucune raison d'être une
borne supérieure sur l'intelligence
physiquement possible pour s'en
convaincre on peut regarder les autres
intelligence qui existe sur terre le
fossé entre les intelligence humaine et
celle disons des dauphins est
monumentale par exemple il me semble
mais je me trompe peut-être que les
dauphins ou non seulement aucune notion
de logique formelle mais il semble même
impossible
leur faire comprendre dans le truc comme
le moule du spawn ans et remplacer
dauphin par grenouille ou parce
qu'arabes et je serai encore un peu plus
confiant leurs limites cognitives
en fait si on met les intelligences des
animaux sur un axe il me suffit l'a pas
dit qu'il fallait pas faire ça ok si on
met les facultés des animaux a effectué
des raisonnements bayésiens on se rend
vite compte que le dernier des abrutis
humain est en fait sur cette échelle
juste à côté du plus grand des gènes
humains qui est peut-être john von
neumann
si vous ne connaissez pas vos neurones
lisez sa page wikipédia anglophone
si l'intelligence artificielle progresse
à un rythme constant le long de cet axe
sachant tout le chemin qu'elle aura dû
parcourir pour arriver jusqu'à nous en
quelques décennies il paraît difficile
d'imaginer qu'elle s'arrêtera à nous
pendant plusieurs décennies
au contraire il semble probable qu'en
l'espace de quelques années voire
peut-être de quelques mois son
intelligence sera passé de celle du plus
six milliards d humains aux plus grands
cerveaux parmi nous c'est ce qui marche
cette illustration de white way on y
voit des humains à une station de train
cette station est la station de
l'intelligence de niveau humain et
regardez là arrivent dit quelqu'un elle
arrive vite se rajoute un autre et le
train passa sans s'arrêter à la station
de l'intelligence de niveau humain li a
pourrait ainsi nous surpasser sans nous
avoir vraiment égalé d'ailleurs on a
déjà un exemple d'une telle remontada
des intelligences artificielles
ainsi en 1997 deep blue fut la première
machine à vaincre d'un champion de
l'échec lors d'un match épique contre
garry kasparov
cependant on peut dire que deep blue
n'avait atteint qu'un niveau humain
puisque le match était très serré
cette bataille entre machines et humains
y aura alors des années puisque autour
de 2003 trois matches finir à égalité
les à partir de 2006 n'y eut plus photo
la machine avait atteint un niveau
surhumain aux échecs
ainsi dans le cas de diplômes il aura
fallu près d'une décennie pour passer de
l'intelligence de niveau humain a une
super intelligence des échecs
cependant cet exemple est trompeur
notamment parce que les successeurs de
deepblue reposait sur des technologies
hardware moins sophistiquée que deep
blue qui tu es vraiment un super
calculateur qui plus est c'était il ya
vingt ans à une époque où la vitesse de
progression désir n'était pas ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui et n'était pas ce
qu'elle sera dans quelques décennies
signa général atteint le niveau humain
or quand on regarde la vitesse
d'adoption des technologies par la
population on se rend compte que la
transition entre technologie prometteuse
et technologies
contournable et de plus en plus rapide
en passant de quelques siècles à
quelques années quand il s'agit de
remonter à des machines
un exemple plus pertinent est sans doute
celui du jeu de go tout d'abord peu de
gens avaient vu venir alpha go il y
adeux deep mind qui triomphe eu ras du
joueur humain lice idole ainsi avant
octobre 2015 les i à 2go devait laisser
des handicaps importants à leurs
adversaires pour espérer rendre le jeu
intéressant à ce moment là les experts
en ia avait prédit qu'il faudra encore
12 ans pour que les surpasse l'humain au
jeu de go mais tout à coup alpha go
surpris tout le monde en battant un
joueur raisonnablement bon puis en mai
2016 alpha yago gagna contre l'une des
pointures mondiales et son était déjà
finie et joueurs humains un an plus tard
alpha go se débarrassa à plat de couture
du numéro un mondial et de quelques
autres joueurs et en octobre 2010 cet
alphabet aux héros fut introduit et
détruisit alpha go par 100 victoires à
zéro plus stupéfiant encore en décembre
unia qui partait de rien alpha 0
s'entraîna pendant seulement 9 heures
pour atteindre un niveau supérieur à
tout moment et à tout autre
iya et cette même il devint aussi numéro
1 mondial aux échecs et eau chaude ou un
autre jeu de plateau cette fois la
transition entre intelligence ou
humaines au jeu de go et intelligence
surhumaine avait eu lieu en l'espace de
quelques mois et la transition de
suremain super intelligent sogo en moins
de deux ans et selon nick votre home il
ya de bonnes chances qu'il en soit de
même pour le problème de l'intelligence
général à un moment où les expert
persisteront à prédire qu'il faudrait au
moins une décennie pour construire une
intelligence général de niveau humain on
pourra tout à coup trouver une façon
d'améliorer nos dires pour qu'elle
atteigne soudainement un niveau
surhumain et puis quelques années voire
quelques mois plus tard cette ya deux
niveaux sur humain pourrait elle même
être très largement surpassé par une
super intelligence et en particulier
tout à coup il y aurait une entité tous
les facultés surpasserait peut-être même
la réunion d intelligence humaine
d'ailleurs à bostrom n'est pas le seul à
être de cet avis voici un extrait d'une
conférence à ce sujet
kobe est bien y réfléchir il me semble
très difficile d'imaginer une
alternative
un tel scénario de décollage rapide de
la super intelligence surtout si cette
liga a accès à internet et de base
aujourd'hui les ja comme celle de
youtube google ou facebook ont accès à
internet
en effet unia qui tout à coup résoudrait
le test de turing sera alors capable
d'écouter et de comprendre la sémantique
du langage main elle pourra alors se
précipiter sur wikipédia et posséder
toute la connaissance basique mène elle
pourra regarder les vidéos de sign for
all et comprendre l'essence des
mathématiques et de sa propre
intelligence elle pourra lire les
dernières publications des chercheurs en
intelligence artificielle et comprendre
mieux que n'importe quel humain comment
améliorer sa propre intelligence elle
pourra rapidement programmé un code qui
correspond à une intelligence
artificielle supérieure à elle même et
l'exécuter sur les centres de données de
google
mieux encore cette nouvelle il pourra
alors mieux comprendre intelligence que
l'ia qui l'a construite ce qui lui
permettra de programmer des liens encore
plus intelligente initiant ainsi une
boucle de rétroaction extrêmement rapide
qui n'a que peu de chances de s'arrêter
bref il semble alors qu'un petit déclic
dont l'intelligence désir conduirait
probablement à un énorme boum dans les
facultés cognitives désir ce qui
conduira alors à l'apparition soudaine
d'une unique super intelligence à côté
de laquelle tout autre ir semblera
ridiculement stupide c'est ce qui est
arrivé avec alpha 0 et il me semble
difficile de ne pas croire que ce soit
ce qui se passera pour la première super
intelligence cette super intelligente ne
sera peut-être pas le résultat d'un long
progrès minutieux planifier et
prévisible elle pourrait bien plus être
le résultat d'une soudaine explosion de
l'intelligence des machines
puis ça fait
analyser et vous avez sans doute envie
de rejeter cette conclusion stupéfiante
souvenez vous que je ne parle pas là de
est-ce que la super intelligence va
bientôt apparaître
je pense qu'on a encore quelques
décennies devant nous même si je ne suis
absolument pas sûr de ce que je dis en
revanche ce qui me semble assez probable
c'est que lorsqu'une ya général
apparaîtra celle ci restera assez
longtemps à un niveau humain uniquement
non à en croire le raisonnement que
soutiennent notamment et les hauts lieux
de cause ce qui est inique post rome et
que vous l'aurez compris je trouve
vraiment convaincant lie à general
passerai rapidement ne pas futé est
largement supérieur à toute l'humanité
combiné est super intelligent ce serait
alors une sorte de bombe à retardement
qu'on risque forte ne pas voir venir
pendant longtemps cette bombe semblera
très inoffensive mais une fois qu'elle
aura explosé en risque fort de ne pas
pouvoir faire marche arrière et de ne
pas comprendre ce qui nous arrive c'est
pour cela que selon lui de kossi et post
rom
ce serait une grossière erreur que
d'attendre l'instant où l'ia générale
s'apprête à exploser
pour anticiper les conséquences de cette
explosion en particulier si cette
première super intelligent c'est une
morale qui diverge fortement de la
morale des humains on risque fort
d'assister à une triste fin de
l'humanité
reste alors à s'assurer que la morale de
la super intelligent ce sera au moins
approximativement aligné avec ce qu'on
voudrait qu'elle fasse sauf que l'un des
gros problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas ce qu'on veut que cette super
intelligent ce passe notamment parce
qu'on a tendance à négliger la
probabilité d'une explosion de
l'intelligence or même si votre créé
dans son ce scénario explosif est faible
même si elle est de 1 pour cent disent
non il vaut mieux anticiper
parce que là on parle vraiment de risque
existentiel quand la première super
intelligence accédera au pouvoir on
pourra vraiment s'attendre au pire ou
omeyer
on pourrait assister à la destruction de
l'humanité ou au contraire à
l'éradication de la faim dans le monde
et des maladies une surabondance des
biens combinée à une préservation des
ressources voire à l'allongement traces
tic de la vie en bonne santé
comme l'expliquent monsieur fille ne
super intelligence est avant tout
fondamentalement imprévisible par nos
cerveaux fini et si vraiment d'imaginer
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête
comme on parlerait comment penserez
comment quelqu'un qui a vécu cinq
siècles analysera une situation
extraordinairement difficile une
dotation d'essayer de se rendre compte à
quel point c'est
fissiles c'est de renverser la
perspective de se dire j'ai essayé
d'imaginer situation symétrique dans
cette situation pour parler de ce
problème là ça serait imaginé une
situation où un enfant de 7 8 ans et
sert et décrira histoire à propos de
notre personnage qui aurait vécu
plusieurs décennies que rêver qu 50 60
ans peut-être pas fou oui avec ceci de
particulier que ce sera un enfant de 7 8
ans qui n'auraient jamais qui vivraient
dans une communauté d'enfants au fait
qu'il n'aurait jamais rencontré l'adulte
qui y vécut entre juste entre enfance
j'ai imaginé ce serait une sorte de
tribut dans cette voie là d'enfants qui
auraient le même genre de cerveau kling
et simplement
physiologiquement sera appelée
différence se développerait beaucoup
plus vite et mon gré vers l'âge de 10-11
ans maximum vous imaginez un enfant 7 8
ans qui serait d'imaginer ce que serait
la société de dom qui vivrait plusieurs
décennies sort par exemple fou parce
qu'on oublie pas plusieurs décennies
pour on sent bien que mal pour essayer
de raconter une histoire autour de tout
ça mais quelque part ce sera un peu à
côté de la plaque ce qui racontera
propos c est ce que marc sens bien déjà
qu'il écrirait pas très bien voilà
et que oeuvrer à ce qu'il explique et
surtout au sujet des adultes de 50 60
ans ce sera vraiment ridicule et
finalement quand brahms aucun essaye
d'écrire dracula il est dans la même
situation il essaye d'écrire les pensées
et le comportement de l'être qui aurait
vécu comme ça qu'ils avaient traversé
plusieurs siècles et quand on lit quand
lee bram stocker et de façon générale
comme lille dans la science fiction dans
le fantastique des personnages pour ce
genre de caractéristiques là et c'est
assez fréquent c'est toujours un peu
raté c'est toujours un peu mauvais et
c'est normal parce qu'en fait ça peut
pas être beau de tout simplement parce
que pour savoir exactement qu'est ce qui
se passera dans la tête de quelqu'un qui
aurait vécu cinq siècles
bah il faudrait il faudrait faudra 20
vécu cinq siècles connaître des gens qui
auraient vécu ça on n'en sait rien
comment réussir à décrire analyser une
intelligence qui serait très supérieure
à la nôtre
ça semble poser un problème radical qui
est qu' on essaie de le faire avec notre
intelligence d'une sortie jans
18 fondamentalement notre capacité à
décrire des intelligences
[Musique]
personnellement quand j'ai pris
conscience de l'ampleur de l'enjeu de la
morale de la super intelligence je me
suis rapidement mis à reconsidérer mes
priorités moral à côté de ce risque
existentiel tous nos débats et nos
divisions politiques habituels ne semble
être qu'une infime goutte d'eau or
déterminer la morale de la super
intelligence est un problème
incroyablement difficile et après avoir
beaucoup lu beauce trône beaucoup écouté
yeux de cause qui est beaucoup regardé
roberte miles
je peux vous garantir une chose ne
résoudrait pas ce problème
en réfléchissant 30 secondes l'imam en
infléchissant 30 heures ou 30 jours
selon bostrom résoudre le problème de
programmer la morale désir est un défi
de recherche digne des plus grands
talents mathématiques de la prochaine
génération et c'est de ça dont on va
parler dans les prochaines vidéos
dernière fois en est à parler de
l'émergence de la singularité ou plus
exactement de ce moment où
l'intelligence artificielle deviendra en
tout point supérieur aion et j'avais
fait un sondage notamment avec google
forme ou s'est demandé de donner vous
avez eu 500 réponses
et voici les résultats compilés bresse
et ses courbes montre ce que vous pensez
de la probabilité qu'il y ait une
indigence de niveau humain alors qu'il a
ses différentes dates dont classés entre
2000 et aujourd'hui et alors 3000 et
c'est ce que j'ai appelé dans le
formulaire avant la nuit des temps voilà
je pense que trop mais c'est extrêmement
éloignée de nous former la vitesse de
pro à des technologies
si ça a fallu avant 3 mais j'ai envie de
dire que ça va très probablement jamais
lieu bref ce graphique montre un peu un
peu différente
prédiction donc par exemple la courbe
bleue donne les prédictions moyenne
probabilité moyenne que vous attribuez
l'émergence d'une ihm c'est la
singularité
ces différentes dates alors que la
courbe rouge donne la note médiane avec
meziane a l'avantagé d'être beaucoup
plus robuste est beaucoup moins sensible
à quelques prédictions à ces extrêmes
par exemple là si on regarde sur la nuit
des temps et bah ouais en fait la grande
majorité d'entre vous pensent que c'est
quelque chose qui te dis à ces câbles
qui va finir par arriver et mais comme
il y en a parmi vous qui pensent que la
singularité n'arrivera jamais ça fait
que la moyenne n'est pas du tout proche
de 100 elle proche même à 80 6 et 1 90%
quelque chose comme ça mais pas
exactement 100 % la courbe orange
correspond aux quand il de 10 %
c'est-à-dire que les 10% les moins
optimistes par rapport à lire d'entre
vous c'est ceux qui prédisent du pur
100e d'entre vous d'humour le plus
pessimiste c'est ce qu'il faut a dit
alors que la courbe verte c'est le 90%
c'est celle inverse donc là sur scène
comme on voit pas forcément ce qui se
passe dans un avenir proche de vous
montrer notre courbe
ces différentes courbes ce sont vos
prédictions sur la franche entre
aujourd'hui et 2100 et finalement je
n'ai pas trop de raison de me sentir
mal à l'aise puisque en fait les
prédictions correspondent grosso modo à
moyenne ou la médiane d'entre vous je
pas du tout quelqu'un d' extrémistes et
il ya quand même pas mal par milou 10 %
qui pensent qu'en fait la singularité et
a de bonnes chances d'être finalement
assez bientôt est en moyenne 10% dans le
permis vous qui pensent que la
singularité pourrait être arrivé en 2025
ce qui est quand même vachement très
bientôt et sachant ce que j'ai dit dans
cette vidéo est ce que selon thomas
parler dans des vidéos à venir
ça fait flipper ça donne envie de faire
beaucoup de recherches sur comment bien
programmé la morale désir et quels sont
les dangers potentiels à différentes
versions de cette morale
or voici les détails de vos prédictions
par rapport à différentes dates donc ça
c'est vos prédictions pour 2025
donc vous êtes quand même pas mal à
trouver très peu de probabilités à ce
qu'est une super intelligent il n'ya de
niveau humain en 2025
mais vous restez tout de même une
majorité à dire que ça reste possible et
qu'une majorité d'entre vous attribue
une priorité non nul à ce qui se passe
un truc assez spectaculaire en 2025
ça fait vraiment vraiment réfléchir et
par contre pour 2035 les choses
deviennent vraiment vraiment sérieuse
puisque si on croit ce que vous en dites
et la finance on croit aussi avait
cherché à retenir est quand même une
probabilité très nombreux ni diable très
très supérieures à un pour mille une
bonne probabilité pour que il se passe
quelque chose d'ici 2035 ce qui fait
vraiment flipper et si on regarde les
1050 là on a plus d'une chance sur deux
d'après vous quels y atteignent le
niveau d'intelligence humaine et ça ça
veut dire que tous les boulots sont
automatisables on a tous les boulots qui
consiste à expliquer transmettre des
données à gérer des papiers tous ces
bobos
pris en 2005 en titre ont disparu avec
une chance sur deux d'après vous et si
on avance dans le temps de 1500 tu dis
ça par contre ça devient même concept
une majorité écrasante au d'entre vous
qui pensent qu'il ya quand même de très
bonnes chances que les désirs de niveau
humain à ces moments là
en fait il ya vraiment pas besoin
d'attendre la fin du siècle si on vous
en croix pour être très très très
concerné par le danger d'une super
intelligence et de tout ce que cela peut
impliquer et du changement de société
qui va falloir préparer dès aujourd'hui
en fait si on prend aux prédictions ont
typiquement un exemple prendre ça un peu
plus concret parce que quand on parle de
tout ça a tendance à laisser des trucs
assez abstrait de façon assez concrète
celui que vous dites c'est que va pour
les jeunes pour les moins de quarante
moins de 50 ans repensez à la retraite
sahara est aujourd'hui puisqu'il risque
qui se passera vraiment quelque chose
d'assez important d'ici quelques
décennies et du coup à personne de 50
ans lorsqu elles partiront à la retraite
bah il faut peut-être 130 qui aura même
plus de job est de toute façon à ce
moment là il faudra avoir complètement
repensé la société jan hein fois que
j'avais aussi parlé de la loi de moore
de cette fois progression exponentielle
des technologies et à izaguirre a fait
remarquer qu'en fait il ya pas mal de
discussions sur le fait que la loi de
moore pourrait arriver à sa fin
pour être déjà à être arrivé à sa fin
notamment parce que les microprocesseurs
atteigne des limites physiques que ce
soit en terme de limites quantique
puisqu'on a un proche au des limites
quantique et du fait que l' on peut pas
mettre des écrans trop proches au sein
qui se passe des trucs quantique à ce
niveau là et que du coup toute la
technologie classique du microprocesseur
ne marche plus on peut plus à
miniaturiser en tout cas donc ça c'est
en effet un autre point important c'est
que l'essai pu en fait chauffe
énormément et c'est pour ça que pendant
longtemps et vitesse de calcul des cpu
début que ces milliards d'esprit
aujourd'hui regardez vous offre votre
ordinateur est souvent giguère tout
moment et ça fait longtemps fait qu'on
en giga hertz qu'on n'a pas augmenté la
vitesse que des procédés
microprocesseurs une bonne raison à cela
c'est que beaucoup plus grande fréquence
correspond plus d'énergie et plus
d'énergie ça veut dire que ça chauffe
et quand ça chauffe pas une limite qui à
la limite de l'évacuation de la chaleur
et ça c'est une limite physique aussi
une force on atteint les limites
physiques
ça veut bien dire qu'on peut pas faire
mieux et en effet les lois de la mode
humour en tout cas on sait les termes là
on atteint les limites physiques du coup
on dit en train de plafonner
ceci étant dit la recherche aujourd'hui
notamment en iran ne nécessite plus
vraiment les cpu est plutôt que miser
sur essai puis aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'architecturé dire repose plus sur les
gpu c'est à dire les cartes graphiques
ou le calcul est très très très
paralléliser en fait lié à ccc
naturellement adapté à faire des calculs
très très paralléliser à cause des
limites de la loi de moore notamment et
du coup aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin de
miniaturiser puisque ça a surtout besoin
de mieux par à l'elysée le calcul est là
par contre on est ultra un an loin
encore des musiques et en cartes de
calcul distribué je pense qu'avoir
beaucoup d'améliorations à venir une
autre grosse amélioration notamment en
termes hardware puisque je pense qu'ils
en ont l'air doit encore beaucoup
progresser si on n'y a eu ni bruit dont
une à une des grosses difficultés du
rappeur c'est que aujourd'hui souvent
les quelques soins encore assez
centralisée et même dans un j'ai pu le
calcul est encore assez centralisée et
c'est qu'on veut tendance si on veut
faire un truc comme le cerveau humain
s'est décentralisé un maximum tous ces
calculs avoir des calculs plus en plus
pas réaliser et si possible avoir des
données qui sont disponibles tout de
suite à côté des unités de calcul parce
qu'aujourd'hui souvent la ram nullité de
mémoire et unités de calcul qui sont
séparés en fait si on essaie de ne plus
manger les deux d'avoir non seulement un
calcul distribué mais aussi un
représentation des données était
décentralisée à ce moment là on pourra
beaucoup plus accéléré lesquels il ya
beaucoup de recharge ce dans ce domaine
il vous renvoie maintenant vers la
présentation des élites saclay de julich
grolier qui est voici qui parle rarement
de ce travail hardware qui a été bon
maintenant nécessaire pour pouvoir faire
des quelques beaucoup plus performant et
si on regarde maintenant c'est que ce
genre de les progrès dans l'ordre
architecture
en gros la loi de moore consiste à
continuer à perdurer j'en veux dire on a
toujours une croissance exponentielle
des puissances de calcul telle mention
ramène ça à l'énergie nécessaire pour
faire ses calculs puissance de calcul
par joule voix dire vraiment des progrès
qui sont impressionnants est vraiment
vraiment exponentielle encore dans tous
ces domaines à le dire lui pose la
question de s qu'il pourrait y avoir un
effondrement des civilisations notamment
pour des raisons environnementales avant
sa singularité
justement c'est intéressant parce que je
n'ai pas mal parlé avec rodolphe de la
chaîne lors éveilleurs tellement je vous
conseille cette vidéo part sur le pic
pétrolier où il parlera de ce risque qui
peut être énorme qui serait un pic
pétrolier il ya plus de pétrole montre
beaucoup moins de pétrole et peut avoir
beaucoup de tension notamment réseau
politique à ce moment là et c'est pose
vraiment la question de crise comment
est ce que l'on pourra réagir à une
chute de la production de pétrole
et voilà qu'après sa vidéo il dit que ça
pourrait arriver entre 2020 et 2050 que
ça pourrait typiquement est trop de
rechange avant la sécurité
potentiellement donc bien sûr c'est très
difficile à exclure et en parlant avec
rodolphe voilà c'est celui qui comprend
mieux ses enjeux et puis moi parce que
j'avais tendance à pas mal sous-estimer
ces risques-là par rapport à haut risque
de deux il ya une super intelligence
notamment mais c'est vrai que c'est les
enjeux et des risques assez préoccupant
après voilà c'est ce que je dis aussi
c'est que je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
éviter ces risques aujourd'hui il me
semble que encore l'une des meilleures
choses à faire c'est vraiment investir
énormément dans la recherche sur des
énergies alternatives sur le stockage
des denrées sur plein de solutions pour
pouvoir avoir un truc pour produire plus
d'énergie plus vert plus plus durables
et moins dépendante des tensions
géopolitiques tout pas mais c'est très
compliqué bien sûr l'avenir est très
difficile à prédire
surtout dans ces domaines mais j'aurais
tendance à dire qu'il faut vraiment
parce que il ya danger là faut vraiment
continuer à faire pas mal de recherches
et peut-être que lille i hate rouvre à
la recherche on y trouvera des solutions
pour rendre
bon jeu pour vraiment faire un percées
technologiques et permettent peut-être
de capturer une fraction beaucoup plus
grande de l'énergie solaire pour qu'elle
puisse remplacer un petite fraction de
l'énergie qui est aujourd'hui extraite
du pétrole s'est énormément dangereux le
futur est peint de d'incertitude et ça
peut aller très bien tout ça peut être
assez catastrophique
elle espère que j'avais mais cet épisode
la prochaine fois on va parler justement
de scénario catastrophe
on va pas faire un truc un peu plus tard
écrit voilà je fais des vidéos assez
difficile dans ces deux faits sur la
sueur sur scène paul et du coup il ya
vraiment des gens qui ont arrêté de
regarder un peu les vidéos et voilà la
semaine prochaine je peux vraiment me
dit nos biens acquis mais certaines
intéressantes qui il a fait huit c'est
vraiment de faire réfléchir
malgré tout rapide technique et histoire
de dire aux gens qu'ils sont abonnés que
voilà 500 euros devient beaucoup plus
simple à comprendre vous parlez de
truies que deux sociétés en plus qui
peut concerner tout le monde et qui sont
très intéressante à mon sens
mathématique
donc c'est ce qu'on va faire la semaine
prochaine si vous avez aimé c'est
l'épisode penser à la ligue et à le
commenter à nous partager pour ça vous
abonner pour enfin sur ces épisodes
verscio ti par paulhan et j'espère que
vous serez là
[Applaudissements]